so you have spoken about a kind of
meaning crisis that we're going through
but it feels like
since uh since we invented sex and death
we broadly speaking we've been searching
for a kind of meaning so it feels like
human civilization has been going
through a meeting crisis of different
flavors throughout its history why is
how is
this particular meeting crisis different
or is it really a crisis and it wasn't
previously what's your sense a lot of
human history there wasn't so much a
meaning crisis there was just a like
food and not getting eaten by bears
crisis right
once you get to a point where you can
make food there was the like not getting
killed by other humans crisis
so sitting around wondering what is all
about is actually a relatively recent
luxury
um
and the and to some extent the meaning
crisis coming out of that is precisely
because
well not precisely because i i believe
that meaning is the consequence of um
when we make consequential decisions
it's tied to agency
right when we make consequential
decisions
that generates meaning so if we make a
lot of decisions but we don't see the
consequences of them then it feels like
what was the point
right but if there's all these big
things happening but we're just along
for the ride then it also does not feel
very meaningful
meaning as far as i can tell is my
working definition circuit 2021
is
uh generally the result of
a person making a consequential decision
acting on it and then seeing the
consequences of it so
historically
just when humans are in survival mode
you're making consequential decisions
all the time
so there's not a lack of meaning because
like you either got eaten or you didn't
right you got some food and that's great
you feel good like these are all
consequential decisions only in
you know the post
fossil fuel and industrial revolution
could we create a massive leisure class
i could sit around not being threatened
by bears
not starving to death
um making and
making decisions somewhat but a lot of
times not making not seeing the
consequences of any decisions they make
the general sort of sense of anamiy i
think this is the french term for it in
the in the wake of the consumer society
in the wake of mass
mass media telling everyone hey you know
choosing between hermes and chanel is a
meaningful decision no it's not
i don't know what either of those means
oh there's high-end uh luxury um uh
purses and crap like that but the point
is that we we give people the idea that
consumption is meaning that making a
choice of this team versus that team
spectating
has meaning so we produce all of these
different things that are
as if meaning right but really making a
decision that has no consequences for us
and so that creates the meaning crisis
well you're saying uh choosing between
chanel and the other one is has no
consequence i mean
why is one more meaningful than the
other it's not that it's more meaningful
the other it's that you make a decision
between these two brands and you're told
this brand will make me look better in
front of other people if i buy this
brand of car
if i wear that brand of apparel right
the idea like a lot of decisions we make
are around consumption but consumption
by itself doesn't actually yield meaning
gaining social status does provide
meaning so that's why in this era of
abundant production
we
so many things turn into status games
the nft kind of explosion is a similar
kind of thing
everywhere there are status games
because
you know
we just have so much excess production
um but aren't those status games a
source of meaning like what why
do the games we play have to be grounded
in physical reality like they are when
you're trying to run away from lions why
can't we
in this virtuality world on social media
why can't we play the games on social
media even the dark ones right we can
and you're but you're saying that's
crazy there's a meaningful crisis well
there's a meeting crisis in that there's
two aspects of it number one
playing those kinds of status games uh
oftentimes requires destroying the
planet
because um
it's it's it ties to consumption
consuming the latest and greatest
version of a thing buying the latest
limited edition sneaker and throwing out
all the old ones maybe it keeps on the
old ones but the amount of sneakers we
have to cut up and destroy every year
to create artificial scarcity for the
next generation right this is kind of
stuff that's not great it's not great at
all
um
so conspicuous consumption
fueling status games is really bad for
the planet not sustainable the second
thing is you can play these kinds of
status games but then what it does is it
renders you captured to the virtual
environment
the status games the really wealthy
people are playing are all around the
hard resources
where they're going to build the
factories they have the fuel in the rare
earths to make the next generation of
robots they're then going to one game
run circles around you and your your
children
so so that's another reason not to play
those virtual status games so you're
saying ultimately the the the big
picture game is won if
by people who have access or control
over actual hard resources so you can't
you don't see a society where most of
the games are um played in the virtual
space they'll be captured in the
physical space it's it it all builds
it's just like the stat the stack of
human being right if you only play
the game at the cultural and
intellectual level and the people the
hard resources and access to layer zero
physical are going to own you
but isn't money not connected to or less
and less connected to hard resources and
money still seems to work it's a virtual
technology um there's different kinds of
money
part of the reason that some of the
stuff is able to go a little unhinged is
because
uh the
the
the big sovereignties
where one spends money and uses money
and plays money games and inflates money
um their their ability to adjudicate
the physical resources and hard
resources on land and things like that
those have not been challenged in a very
long time
so you know we went off the gold
standard most money is not connected to
physical resources
it's an idea
and that
idea is
very closely connected to status
um so why but it's also tied to like
it's actually tied to law it's it is
tied to some physical hard things so you
have to pay your taxes yes so it's
always at the end
going to be connected to the uh the
blockchain of physical reality so in the
case of law and taxes it's connected to
government
and uh government is what violence
is the i'm playing with the monopoly
devil's advocates here
uh and popping one devil off the stack
at a time
isn't ultimately of course it'll be
connected to physical reality but just
because people control the physical
reality doesn't mean the status
lebron james in theory could make more
money than the owners of the teams
in theory and to me that's a virtual
idea so somebody else constructed a game
and now you're playing in the space of
virtual uh in the virtual space of the
game so it just feels like there could
be games where status we build realities
that give us meaning in the virtual
space like i can imagine such things
being possible oh yeah okay so i see
what you i think i see what you're
saying there with the idea that i mean
we'll take the lebron james side and put
in like some youtube influencer yes sure
right so the youtube influencer
it is status games but at a certain
level it precipitates into real dollars
and into like well you look at mr beast
right he's like
sending off half a million dollars worth
of fireworks or something right on a
youtube video and also like saving you
know like saving trees and so on sure
right you're trying to plant a milling
tree with a mark robert or whatever it
was yeah like it's not that those kinds
of games can't lead to real consequences
it's that for the vast majority of
people in consumer culture
they are incented by the
i would say mostly i'm thinking about
middle class consumers
they're incented by advertisements
they're centered by their memetic
environment to treat
the
purchasing of certain things the need to
buy the latest model whatever they need
to appear however the need to pursue
status games
as a driver of meaning and my point
would be that it's a very hollow driver
of meaning
and that is what creates a meaning
crisis because at the end of the day
it's like eating a lot of empty calories
right yeah it tasted good going down a
lot of sugar but man it did not it was
not enough protein to help build your
muscles and you kind of feel that in
your gut
and i think that's i mean to all the
stuff aside and setting aside a
discussion on currency which i hope we
get back get back to
that's what i mean about the meaning
crisis part of it being created by the
fact that we don't
um we're not
encouraged to have more and more direct
relationships we're actually alienated
from relating to even even our family
members sometimes right we're we're
encouraged to relate to brands we're
encouraged to relate to these kinds of
things that then tell us
to um do things that are really of low
consequence
and that's where the meaning crisis
comes from so the role of technology in
this so there's somebody you mentioned
who's jacques
elio
his view of technology
he warns about the towering piles of
technique which i guess is a broad idea
of technology yes so i think correct me
if i'm wrong for him technology is a is
a is bad moving away from human nature
and it's ultimately destructive
my question broadly speaking this
meeting crisis can technology what are
the pros and cons of technology can it
be a good yeah i think it can be i
certainly draw on some of the lowell's
ideas and i i think some of them are are
pretty good um but the way he defines
technique is
uh well also symmondon as well i mean he
speaks to the general mentality of
efficiency
homogenized processes homogenize
production homogenized labor to produce
homogenized artifacts
that then are not actually
they don't sit well in the environments
it's essentially you can think of as the
antonym of um craft
whereas a craftsman will come
to you know a problem uh maybe a piece
of wood and then make it to a chair it
may be a site to build a house or build
a stable or build you know whatever
and they will consider how to bring
various things in to build something
well contextualized that's in uh
in right relationship with that
environment
but the way we have driven technology
over the last 150 years is not that at
all it is how can we
you know make sure the input materials
are homogenized cut to the same size you
know
diluted and doped exactly the right
alloy concentrations how do we create
machines that then consume exactly the
right kind of energy to be able to run
at this high speed to stamp out the same
parts which then go out the door
everyone gets the same tickle me elmo
and the reason why everyone wants it is
because we have broadcast that tells
everyone this is the cool thing so we
homogenize demand right and we're like
beaujolaire um and like other critiques
of modernity coming from that direction
you know the situation list as well they
it's that their point is that at this
point in time consumption is the thing
that drives a lot of the economic stuff
not the need but the need to consume and
build status games on top
so we have homogenized when we
discovered i think this is uh this is
really like bernays and stuff right in
the early 20th century we discovered we
can create
we can create demand we can create
desire
in a way that
was not possible before because of
broadcast media
and one not only do we create desire we
don't create a desire for each person to
connect to some bespoke thing to build a
relationship with their neighbor or
their spouse we are telling them you
need to consume this brand you need to
drive this vehicle you got to listen to
this music have you heard this have you
seen this movie right so creating
homogenized demand
makes it really cheap to create
homogenized product and now you have
economics of scale so we make the same
tickle me elmo give it to all the kids
and all the kids are like hey i got to
tickle my elbow right so this is
ultimately
where this ties in then to run away
hyper capitalism is that we then
capitalism is always looking for growth
it's always looking for growth and
growth only happens the margins so you
have to squeeze more and more demand out
you got to make it cheaper and cheaper
to make the same thing but tell everyone
they're still getting meaning from it
you're still like this is still your
tickle me elmo right and we we see
little bits of this
dripping critiques of this dripping in
popular culture you see it sometimes
it's when buzz lightyear
walks into the thing he's like oh my god
at the toy store i'm just a toy like
there's millions of other or there's
hundreds of other buzz lightyears just
like me right
that is i think you know of a fun pixar
critique on this homogenization dynamic
you